i will never forget the first time i
visited a client in jail
the heavy metal door slammed behind me
and i heard the key
turn in the lock the cement floor
underneath me had a
sticky film on it that made a ripping
sound like
tape being pulled off a box every time i
moved to my foot
the only connection to the outside world
was a small window
placed too high to see there was a small
square table bolted to the floor
and two metal chairs one on either side
that was the first time i understood
viscerally
just for a fleeting moment what
incarceration might feel like
and i promised myself all those years
ago as a young public defender
that i would never ever forget that
feeling
and i never have it inspired me to fight
for each and every one of my clients
freedom
as if it was my own
freedom a concept so fundamental to the
american psyche
that it is enshrined in our constitution
and yet america is addicted to
imprisonment
from slavery through mass incarceration
it always
has been look we all know the shocking
numbers
the united states incarcerates more
people per capita than almost
any nation on the planet but what you
may not know
is that on any given night in america
almost half a million people go to sleep
in those concrete jail cells
who have not been convicted of anything
these mothers and fathers and sons and
daughters are there
for one reason and one reason only they
cannot afford to pay the price of their
freedom
and that price is called bail
now bail was actually created as a form
of conditional release
the theory was simple set bail in an
amount that somebody could afford to pay
they would pay it it would give them an
incentive to come back to court it would
give them some skin in the game
bale was never intended to be used as
punishment
bail was never intended to hold people
in jail cells
and bail was never ever intended
to create a two-tier system of justice
one for the rich
and one for everybody else but that is
precisely what it is done
75 percent of people in american local
jails are there because they cannot pay
bail
people like ramel on a chilly october
afternoon
ramel was riding his bicycle in his
south bronx neighborhood on his way to a
market to pick up a quart of milk
he was stopped by the police and when he
demanded to know why he was being
stopped
an argument ensued and the next thing he
knew he was on the ground in handcuffs
being charged with riding her bicycle on
the sidewalk
and resisting arrest he was taken to
court where a judge set
five hundred dollars bail but romell
he didn't have five hundred dollars so
this 32 year old father
was sent to the boat a floating jail
barge
that sits on the east river between a
sewage plant
and a fish market that's right
you heard me in new york city in 2018
we have a floating prison barge that
sits out there and houses primarily
black and brown men who cannot pay their
bail
let's talk for a moment about what it
means to be in jail
even for a few days well
it can mean losing your job losing your
home
jeopardizing your immigration status it
may even mean
losing custody of your children a third
of sexual victimization by jail staff
happens in the first three days in jail
and almost half of all jail deaths
including suicides
happen in that first week what's more
if you're held in jail on bail you're
four times more likely to get a jail
sentence than if you had been free
and that jail sentence will be three
times longer
and if you are black or latino and cash
bail has been set
you are two times more likely to remain
stuck in that jail cell
than if you were white jail in america
is a terrifying dehumanizing and violent
experience imagine for just
one moment that it's you stuck in that
jail cell
and you don't have the five hundred
dollars to get out
and someone comes along and offers you a
way out
just plead guilty they say you can go
home back to your job
just plead guilty you can kiss your kids
good night tonight
so you do what anybody would do in that
situation
you plead guilty whether you did it or
not
but now you have a criminal record
that's going to follow you for the rest
of your life
jailing people because they don't have
enough money to pay bail is one of the
most unfair
immoral things we do as a society but it
is also
expensive and counterproductive american
taxpayers
they spend 14 billion dollars annually
holding people in jail cells who haven't
been convicted of anything that's
40 million dollars a day
what's perhaps more confounding is it
doesn't make us any safer
research is clear that holding somebody
in jail makes you significantly more
likely to commit a crime when you get
out
than if you have been free all along
freedom makes all the difference
low-income communities and communities
of color have known that for generations
together they have pooled their
resources to buy their loved ones
freedom
for as long as bondage and jail cells
existed
but the reach of the criminal legal
system has grown to enormous and the
numbers are just too large
99 percent of jail growth in america
has been the result over the last 20
years
of pre-trial incarceration
i have been a public defender for over
half my life and i have stood by
and watched thousands of clients as they
were dragged into those jail cells
because they didn't have enough money to
pay bail
i have watched as questions of justice
were subsumed by questions of money
calling into question the legitimacy of
the entire american legal system
i am here to say something simple
something obvious but something urgent
freedom makes all the difference
and freedom should be free
but how are we going to make that happen
well that's the question i was wrestling
with
over a decade ago when i was sitting at
a kitchen table with my husband david
who was also a public defender
we were eating our chinese takeout and
venting about the injustice of it all
when david looked up and said why don't
we just start a bail fund and just start
bailing our clients out of jail
and in that unexpected moment the idea
for the bronx freedom fund
was born look we didn't know what to
expect
there were plenty of people that told us
we were crazy and we're going to lose
all of the money
people wouldn't come back because they
didn't have any stake in it
but what if clients did come back we
knew that bail money comes
back at the end of a criminal case so it
could come back into the fund
and we could use it over and over again
for more and more
bail that was our big bet and that bet
paid off over the past 10 years we have
been paying bails
for low-income residents of new york
city and what we have learned
have exploded our ideas of why people
come back to court
and how the criminal legal system itself
is operating
turns out money isn't what makes people
come back to court
we know this because when the bronx
freedom fund pays bail
ninety-six percent of clients return for
every court appearance
laying waste to the myth that it's money
that mattered
it's powerful evidence that we don't
need
cash or ankle bracelets or unnecessary
systems of surveillance and supervision
we simply need court reminders simple
court reminders about when to come back
to court
next we learned that if you're held in
jail on a misdemeanor
90 percent of people will plead guilty
but when the fund pays bail
over half the cases are dismissed
and in the entire history of the bronx
freedom fund
fewer than two percent of our clients
have ever received
a jail sentence of any kind
ramel a week later he was still on the
boat
locked in that jail cell he was on the
cusp of losing everything
and he was about to plead guilty and the
bronx freedom fund intervened and paid
his bail
now reunited with his daughter he was
able to fight his case from outside
look it took some time two years to be
exact
but at the end of that his case was
dismissed in its entirety
for ramel
for rimmel the bronx freedom fund was a
lifeline
but for countless other americans locked
in jail cells there is no freedom fund
coming
it's time to do something about that
it's time to do something
big it's time to do something bold
it's time to do something maybe
audacious
we want to take our proven revolving
bail fund model that we built in the
bronx
and spread it across america attacking
the front end of the legal system
before incarceration begins
here's the plan we're going to bail out
as many people as we can as quickly as
we can
over the next five years partnering with
public defenders and local community
organizations
we're going to set up 40 sites in high
knee jurisdictions the goal
is to bail out 160 000 people
our strategy leverages the fact that
bail money comes back at the end of the
case
data from the bronx shows that a dollar
in bail can be used two or three times a
year
creating a massive force multiplier so a
dollar donated today
can be used to pay bail for up to 15
people
over the next five years our strategy
also relies
on the experience and the wisdom and the
leadership
of those who have experienced this
injustice first
hand each bail project
site will be staffed by a team of bail
disruptors
these are passionate dedicated advocates
from local
communities many of whom are formally
incarcerated themselves
who will pay bails and support clients
while their cases are going through the
legal system providing them whatever
resources
and support they may need our first two
sites
are up and running one in tulsa oklahoma
and one in st louis missouri
and ramel he's training right now to be
a bail disrupter in queens county new
york
our next three sites are ready to launch
in dallas
detroit and louisville kentucky the bail
project
will attack the money bail system on an
unprecedented scale
we will also listen collect
and elevate and honor the stories of our
clients so that we can change hearts and
minds
and we will collect critical national
data
that we need so we can chart a better
path forward
and that so that we do not recreate this
system of oppression
in just another form the bail project by
bailing out 160 000 people over the next
five years
will become one of the largest
non-governmental decarcerations
of americans in history so look
the criminal legal system as it exists
it needs to be dismantled
but here's the thing i know from decades
in the system real systemic change
takes time and it takes a variety of
strategies so it's going to take
all of us it's going to take the civil
rights litigators the community
organizers
the academics the media the
philanthropists the students the singers
the poets
and of course the voices and efforts of
those who who are impacted by this
system
but here's what i also know together
i believe we can end mass incarceration
but one last thing those people
sitting in america in those jail cells
in every corner of the country
who are held in jail on bail bondage
right now
they need a lifeline today that's where
the bail project comes in
we have a proven model a plan of action
and a growing network of bail
destructors who are audacious enough
to dream big and fight hard one bale at
a time
for as long as it takes until true
freedom
and equal justice are a reality in
america
you